let's just bring you some breaking news
from uh Court this is about an armed
metropolitan police officer 48 year old
David Carrick and he served with the
Parliamentary and diplomatic protection
command and worked on the Parliamentary
estate while in court this morning he
has pleaded guilty to a string of
offenses against women including 24
counts of rape against 12 women these
all date between 2003 and 2020. so this
is serving metropolitan police officer
David Carrick who's 48 pleading guilty
to 49 offenses including 24 counts of
rape against 12 women over quite a
substantial time period
2003 and 2020.
at the outset I want to command the
outstanding bravery of the 13 women who
came forward and reported the horrific
crimes they were victims of
on behalf of the Metropolitan Police
Service
I am truly sorry that they have suffered
at the hands of this police officer
Carrick is a prolific serial sex
offender
who pred on women over a period of many
years
abusing his possession as a police
officer and committing the most horrific
degrading crimes
he has devastated women's lives
he's had a devastating impact on the
trust and confidence of women and girls
that we are working so hard to earn
he's devastated colleagues
was much of his founding was not known
to the Met
there was an escalation of abusive
behaviors that should have been
identified and the matters have been
referred to the iopc
I would not expect anyone with his
pattern of behavior to be in the police
service today
or work to identify on the ridge met of
corrupt officers is determined and it is
focused and it will continue
given that you have set out for us today
all of the things that he was
investigated for the allegations that
were made against him the reports that
were made against him
isn't it astonishing that this man was
allowed to remain a serving police
officer for as long as he was
this is a matter that we are truly sorry
for we have missed opportunities over
time to identify a pattern of abusive
Behavior we're truly sorry for the fact
he continued to be a police officer he
abused that poor that he had as a police
officer and and used that to control the
women who were his victims and I'm so
sorry that that will have prolonged the
suffering that those women have had and
I'm a total awe of them coming forward
now and seeing him to a successful
conviction what is being done now what
reassurances can you give
public that officers like him are being
rooted out and kicked out of the force
we are very clear on our commitment to
identify these officers there have been
huge amounts of investment over the last
year to um to really improve our ability
to identify such officers and staff to
investigate those officers and staff
we have created a domestic abuse and
sexual offending team with over 50
dedicated specialist officers to um to
provide those investigations those
specialist at investigations we have
created an anti-corruption command unit
and we have invested significantly in
the intelligence capability for them we
are using and doing everything that we
can to root out these evil and
corrupting officers
I mean it's it's no doubt true that
there will be some officers still
serving who you would like to see the
back of Carrick used his position as a
police officer to intimidate people into
not reporting him
um is it possible that that is still
going on today and if so what would you
say to the potential victims
so I can never guarantee that there
isn't another sex offender within the um
within the Metropolitan Police Service
but what I can say with absolute
confidence is that we are determined and
that we are doing so much to identify
who those officers may be and to ensure
that every investigative action that we
can do and support that we can provide
victims is in place and that we can
bring those people forward to Justice
and get them out of this policing
organization